our vehicle is constructed from foam
with carbon fiber-reinforced wings it
has a single control surface at the tail
which is controlled by a hobby servo
motor for our experiment we will only
consider the aircraft's lateral planar
dynamics for tracking the aircraft's
position will use a vikon motion capture
studio we will define our perching
maneuver as the aircraft starting 3.5
meters from the perch at 7 meters per
second and landing in a six point five
centimeter capture region with less than
one meter per second of forward velocity
we demonstrate the robustness of our
system by throwing the glider by hand
landing on powerlines to recharge it
provides a unique opportunity to improve
the mission duration of unmanned aerial
vehicles in this project we explore
whether or not we can successfully perch
on a powerline with a fixed-wing UAV
using only the magnetic field generated
by the powerline to localize the
aircraft these results demonstrate the
magnetic field based estimates are
sufficient for achieving closed-loop
perching and could be a reliable means
of perching on power lines in the field
finally we take our powerline perching
glider outdoors and demonstrate that we
are able to perch successfully in
outdoor environments when wind is
limited